ulrich bruckner analyste politique c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
bonsoir rica bruckner merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france contrôles à
la frontière avec la france ça y est on
change d'avis on va enfin contrôler les
frontières
désormais cela a toujours été une option
si nécessaire nous l'avons bien vu lors
d'événements sportifs nationaux afin
d'éviter l'afflux de hooligans et il
s'agit ici d'arrêter le flux libre du
virus donc cela fait sens et cela ne
remet pas en question fondamentalement
l'idée de l'ouverture des frontières
dans la zone schengen vont consister ces
contrôles de frontières parce qu'on sait
que de nombreux notamment aux
strasbourgeois francis en chine chaque
jour cette frontière qui vous sépare de
la france comment ça va se passer
comment on va gérer ces personnes on a
fait une faute je pense qu'il s'agit
d'une action symbolique afin de montrer
aux personnes qui souhaitent pénétrer en
allemagne ainsi qu'aux citoyens
allemands que l'état est conscient des
conséquences de la libre circulation du
virus
idéalement il faudrait réduire les
contacts sociaux autant que possible le
contrôle aux frontières et le contrôle
de la température en cas de doute
n'empêche pas à la circulation du virus
mais crée une sensation une prise de
conscience qui vraiment nécessaire que
je me rende ou devrais-je plutôt rester
à la maison au sein de la communauté
alors la france doit prendre la mesure
du danger disait encore cet après midi
des correspondants italiens en allemagne
est-ce que de votre côté vous estimez
que votre pays a pris la mesure du
danger
bien sûr l'allemagne a pris la mesure du
danger le développement de cette
pandémie dépens en fonction des
personnes étudiées l'explosion quasiment
dans certains pays comme en corée ou en
italie a été plus rapide que dans
d'autres pays l'allemagne est bien
consciente que cela pourrait également
arriver ici le fait que les chiffres
soient plus basse que dans d'autres pays
ne signifie pas que cela ne peut pas
arriver il faudrait autant que possible
retardé mais il est impossible de
l'empêcher on dit souvent qu'un gala
merkel elle n'est pas très friand teint
de ses conférences de presse
quotidiennes on a vu beaucoup nous en
france emmanuel macron tous les jours en
visite sur les chaînes info tantôt dans
un ehpad tantôt dans un hôpital à google
américaine elle quel est son mode de
communication l'a vu s'exprimer
récemment mais est-ce qu'elle est plutôt
discrète les allemands sont satisfaits
en tout cas de ce traitement de la crise
par la chancelière
mon frère se voir les chevaux 4 tout
d'abord il ne faut pas oublier que nous
avons des systèmes politiques très
différents le système présidentiel en
france un président très expansif
c'est différent en matière de
personnalités comme en matière de rôle
politique que la merkel s'est depuis
2015 qu'elle peut bien gérer une crise à
traiter les problèmes tels que la crise
lehman fukushima l'occupation de la
crimée et la crise grecque
la crise en grèce et elle gère également
la crise actuelle avec l'afflux des
migrants en nombre aujourd'hui il s'agit
d'une catastrophe naturelle
et elle essaie de dire que en ce moment
il n'est pas nécessaire de faire des
actions politiques symboliques
elle fait confiance à la solidité du
système fédéral à loin avec ses
différentes couches et elle pense que le
ministre travaille bien qu'il faut
coopérer
on sait angela merkel très attachée aux
dogmes européen en tout cas du déficit
de 2 3 % on l'a entendu dire que
quelques soirées le coup en tout cas la
santé des allemands seraient
prioritaires ça vous a étonné vous en
tant que observateurs cela ne me
surprend pas car elle a toujours voulu
trouver des solutions au niveau européen
le pire serait d'essayer de trouver des
responsables de montrer des pays de
dénoncer des pays qui seraient plus ou
moins responsable
nous devons tous faire notre possible et
l'idéal serait de bien nous coopérer
c'est extrêmement important dans les
régions frontalières notamment et je
pense également que nous trouvons une
solution européenne
merci beaucoup ulrich bruckner un avis
positif d'avoir été en direct avec nous
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir merci à
vous